I've always been the type of lady
to go after what I want.
Hey boy, you want, you want... I got you a present. You're a good looking boy, you want to come home with me?
Can I be your mom?
Look.. I.. if I were your mom I'd shower
you with gifts. Come on!
Hey! Hey, come here.
I was talking to a friend the other day.
Who told me,
Friend: I've been trying to send him signals,
but I just don't think he's picking up on them.
Anna: Why don't you just ask him out?
[Laughter]
Good one.
Oh, you're serious...
Oh...
No, no I can't do that.
Why?
Well, I mean...
Now I've always aggressively
chased the boys that I've liked.
When I was a kid I would make it
abundantly clear if I liked-liked you.
As an adult, my habits haven't really changed.
That's a cute picture of me, huh?
(It was when) I was a kid, yeah
Good looker
But I've been surprised to find
that a lot of my female friends
are very reluctant to ask guys out.
When I ask them about it,
they have all kinds of excuses.
I don't know.
Guys love the chase.
I'm not aggro like you, Anna.
I don't think I could handle that kind of rejection.
So ladies, I have three very good reasons
why you should ask the next guy out.
One.
What's the worst that could happen?
He says no.
So what?
Rejection's not the end of the world,
and that kind of pressure is something that guys face
every single time they want to ask a woman out.
Two.
Time.
I don't about you, but when I'm crushing
on someone, I waste so much time
fantasizing about what their butt looks like.
Just ask them out.
Get some answers.
Get that butt.
Three.
Missed Opportunities.
Look. Putting yourself out there
and putting your feelings out there
is very vulnerable and scary;
it's a hard thing to do.
But some guys are maybe too shy to ever do that,
so imagine all of the missed
loves that you never had
because you were both too afraid
to approach each other.
Plus, think about how much easier this
would make the whole dating process.
If you aren't asking people out,
you're basicly sitting around,
waiting for someone to come find you
You want to know how Brad and I started dating?
I asked him out;
I hit him up on Facebook,
and I said hey I think you're cute,
and I'd like to take you out to dinner,
and we ended up chatting
about his childhood ferrets till 4 a.m.
But, I've also been rejected a lot
throughout the years by guys
who either didn't like how aggressive I was,
or didn't like me as person,
or didn't find me attractive, or I don't know.
They don't always tell me.
So, who knows? Go out there lady friends.
I implore you!
And the next time you see a cutie,
hit him up.
I'd like to ask you out
Um, with this. Here.
That's a present for you.
'Cause I think you're real cute,
and I wanna show you that I,
that I like you, and I want to cuddle.
Thanks so much to Lootcrate
for sponsoring today's video.
For those of you who don't know,
Lootcrate creates cool subscription boxes
that have a new theme every month.
It's like a surprise present to yourself
or to your kitties!
You have untill the 19th of the month to order,
because they all ship out at the end of the month,
and you can order just one crate
or subscribe for the gift that keeps on giving.
So I got December's galaxy themed loot pets box,
which—I've never unboxed
anything before so this is exciting.
Oh, it's cute!
It came with galactic snacks
freezedried beef liver snacks for dogs!
I have four cats so maybe they can eat that,
even though they're not dogs.
Oh, they've got a pet collar,
that looks kind of futuristic.
We got a new bowl!
That's perfect 'cause we broke a bowl the other day
It's a firefly troublemaker ceramic pet bowl.
Thank you.
Oh my god, it's a sweater? Is it a sweater?
It's a tank top!
Oh my god!
They have their own magazine!
and it's a pug!
January's theme is Invasion. You can sign up
by clicking on the link below in my video description,
and don't forget to sign up by the 19th
at 9 p.m. pacific to get January's crate.